I have never been and I've never wanted
to be a career politician my aim in
being in politics was to get Britain out
of the European Union that is what we
voted for in that referendum there two
weeks ago and that is why I now feel
that I've done my bit that I couldn't
possibly achieve more than we managed to
get in that referendum and so I feel
it's right that I should now stand aside
as leader of UK I will continue to
support the party I will support the new
leader I will watch the renegotiation
process in Brussels like a hawk
and perhaps comment in the European
Parliament from time to time
I'm also very keen to help the
independence movements that are
springing up in other parts of the
European Union because I'm certain the
one thing you haven't seen the last
country that wants to leave the EU it
has been a huge chunk of my life doing
this and it's not easy perhaps when you
feel a degree of ownership of something
to let it go but it does come as I say
at a cost has come a cost to me and
perhaps to those around me during the
referendum campaign I said I want my
country back and what I'm saying today
is I want my life back and it begins
right now thank you